that's what's happening I see you know
I'm name is Grace help me no no you know
your life it's different now welcome to
my youtube channel I'm gonna do
something on this channel that I hardly
ever do I'm going to read a book my
parents are divorced and they're all
remarried and they're all retired now
and all of them seem to be going through
all of the archives of all the [ __ ] that
my brothers and I have accumulated as
children my stepmom recently texted me
and said that she found a bunch of
college papers and like stuff that she
thought might be of importance to me I
wanted to do screenwriting when I was in
college so there's a lot of like half
written scripts that she found that I
was like yeah sure send them to me not
only did she send me a bunch of like
half written scripts written by 19 year
old grace she sent this it's a book and
that's an idiot my stepmom you mean no
forewarning that this was gonna be in
the box of college screenplays that's
assuming I was getting I haven't opened
this at all I thought it might be best
to open it on camera what better way to
share the most intimate raw candid
thoughts
I guess elementary school grace if this
was College Grace that made this oh
welcome to all about me by grace hall
but look at this this is me I guess that
I drew and then I colored over
everything then someone that loves
coffee and gripping things with wet
hands got a hold of this JK Rowling's in
the making my apologies if the lighting
changes I still don't actually know what
age I was when I made this book all
about me
by grace velvet December 1991 I was six
years old when I wrote this book Oh
genius
suck my six-year-old dick New York Times
note I gotta talk to my publisher
because I lied to her and I told her
that I had never written a book before I
sided with her oh it's already sweet and
sad because a child did it and the child
is me my name is grace Helbig I am six
years old I
yes it's me I put a speech bubble next
to my mouth and that has the letter M in
it and then I erased it and ain't that
just the case too afraid to speak up
ghosts like tree things are hovering
above me and then there's like this blue
amorphous shape next to me which is
maybe a pool the time warp that I hoped
existed when I was six so I can just
like speed through adolescence I think
that's a flower and not a fire so far
everything checks out this is my family
there are five people in my family
so this penmanship is not the penmanship
of a six-year-old my dad my mom Tim John
and me
I drew my dad standing on my older
brother's shoulders cuz I guess maybe
secretly I wish that we were like in
Cirque du Soleil and also Tim I put them
in pink shorts so it's as if I knew this
is my house I live it don't look at the
address that I don't live at anymore and
made my house look like an angry
Christmas tree that's just housing
cigarette that's fun I put a purple
flower it was an artist like I had a
signature also there's a lot of scum on
this page oh the scum gets worse this is
my mom she lets me play with my friends
and then I guess I drew my mom with her
full curly permed hair and then she's by
a lake with like a glowworm looking
thing which is true my mom loves going
outside and looking at turkey vultures
this is my dad he plays with me just
true my dad would take us outside and
we'd like do sports and things like that
which i think is what this hop scotch
ladder scenario is yeah my dad didn't do
like fire drills with us he just like we
did a bunch of like athletics and sports
we didn't watch a lot of TV other than
SNL Monty Python that's all we watched
and then we go outside and do sports and
that's why I'm so strong and funny
there's a couple other people in the
background that look like they're
struggling I think those are meant to be
my brothers my dad and I are like
succeeding at sports and then my other
part not doing so well
I had a healthy sense of ego even as a
six-year-old my favorite thing to do is
play with my cat what we were younger we
had a cat named Tigger and I guess at
that time I convinced myself that I like
to play with Tigger deep down I did not
like Tigger Tigger is an outdoor cat and
I was in fourth or fifth grade just left
the family to go die my mom told us that
he wasn't coming back and they he he
left the family to go die and we never
talked about it again
Tigger did the ultimate Irish goodbye
maybe that cat shaped like my actual
relationships adults more than anyone
else in my family that I could think of
wow this book is enlightening I love
food pizza is the best Wow we were so
young we were literally so young our
gastrointestinal system couldn't digest
cheese yes Pizza is the best but hey it
sucks your grades it's gonna become your
enemy also you're never gonna like
purple or pink and you're gonna hate
wearing skirts so I am learning to read
my favorite book is Little Red Riding
Hood the accompanying image is just a
door with stairs nothing about Little
Red Riding Hood this is what I think I
associated reading with which is school
when I grow up I would like to be a
horseback rider oh yeah and I did want
to ride horses until I realized I was
scared of them here's me riding a horse
into some sort of tiny tornado trash
bins head on and only jumping never
touching the ground I like it best when
my family plays with me oh it's kind of
fact this is my family we all love me on
my cat's name is Tigger
it is a crazy cat it bites me a lot and
runs around this is the last page of my
all about me is that I had more to say
about my cabin let the one page about me
playing with my cat being my favorite
thing go aside I had to let everyone
know it's a crazy cat it bites me and it
runs around the light yeah that cat was
nuts that cat left us to go die I'm glad
six-year-old greys wanted to make sure
if Rick's great teacher knew I had more
to say about that goddamn cat
no chemistry here lied probably in the
first half of this book and I'm glad I
had one last page to set the record
straight the end that's for sure my
handwriting and I tried to write it in
cursive because I thought I was pretty
great Wow so did you learn any more
about me than you already knew in the
last 10 years of me posting YouTube
videos I learned more about me secure
old me made sure to speak out about the
creature in its life no follow-up
questions about how I own a dog that's
currently very aggressive that's it for
this video it's a quick fun little thing
that I thought would be fun to share
with you you like to give it a thumbs up
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
make videos also if you don't know I
have a podcast called not too deep every
Monday it comes out and every Monday on
this channel there's a video portion of
the podcast and the other podcast I do
with my best friend mamrie Hart as you
all know called this make it weird goes
up every Wednesday and we are going on
tour we're going to 7 different cities
all the links for all the tickets are
down below we're going to Phoenix
Minnesota Detroit Portland Seattle not
in that order they're all down there
we haven't been on tour in a few years
so we're primed and ready I got a lot of
cat conversation that I need to get out
it's been in my body for apparently 27
years now other than that I don't know
[Music]